[Music]
a big murmur went through the movie
world when it was reported last week
that warner brothers has completely
canceled the new batgirl movie although
it was as good as finished now it is
still uncertain how to proceed with many
other projects that are currently still
in production at dc at least there are
news about a few projects that probably
do not fall victim to the decisions of
the management around ceo david zazloff
for example blue beetle which is
supposed to be the first dc movie with a
latin american superhero is still in
production as planned fans were worried
here because the movie like batgirl was
originally planned for hbo max was then
to be shot for theaters in august 2023
we will probably be able to see sholom
arduino in the leading role who will
embody the dc character blue beetle also
secured or joker fellaia do in the flash
although with the latter more and more
scandals around leading actor ezra
miller are coming to light some projects
in which james gunn is involved will not
be shredded either accordingly work
continues on the second season of the
peacemaker series as well as on a yet
unknown amanda waller series in addition
the birds of prey spin off about black
canary and the green lantern live action
series are still in the works we are
curious to see how warner brothers will
continue its strategy of major
theatrical productions and are looking
forward to the upcoming projects for now
this week there was a whole series of
new images for the fifth season cobra
kai on netflix among other things we
also see sean kanan as mike barnes and
thus back in his old role as a villain
which he also played in the karate kid
part 3. back then he was the henchman of
terry silver and regularly caused
trouble for daniel this now also
confirms what fans have been speculating
for quite some time the events of the
fifth season immediately follow on from
the fourth season and present terry
silver with the fact that he is pretty
much on his own and can use all the help
we can get also appearing in pictures
are peyton list as torrey and sholo mara
dwina is miguel however there is still
no sign of martin cove as john keys as
he is known to have gone to prison in
addition to mara dwayna new cast members
include corey hengeler as amanda russo
tanner buchanan is johnny's son robbie
keane and mary mouser is his daughter
samantha larusso you don't have to wait
too much longer for the release because
netflix is releasing all 10 episodes at
once on september 9th 2022
sonic the hedgehog has won the hearts of
fans with two movies so far that there
will be at least a third one has been
confirmed for several months and now we
also know when it will hit theaters the
release has been set for december 20th
2024 by paramount pictures so far
details about the content are still
being kept under wraps by both the film
studio and sega however it can be
assumed that the hero trio around sonic
knuckles and tails will have to deal
with even greater threats than dr
robotnik at the same time work is being
done on a series revolving around
knuckles which should be released on
paramount plus in the course of the
coming year there have already been
words of praise from director jeff
fowler who expressed his belief that
knuckles will definitely thrill fans he
added that there are also countless
possibilities for how to approach the
character and the series making him
excited to finally introduce the series
to viewers just as in sonic the hedgehog
2 knuckles will be voiced by idris elba
[Music]
until the release of the new iron heart
series we must remain patient until the
end of 2023 however we already got a
first look at the iron man successor in
the mcu this week taken from the
shooting first there are two images of
dominique thorne as the young inventor
riri williams who is shown in a rather
monstrous outfit the suit which is
somewhat reminiscent of the hulkbuster
is pretty close to the comic book
original where she puts it together from
various stolen materials from the mit
also there is probably some vibranium
from wakanda built in after all that's
where she meets t'challa's sister shuri
but not only riri presents herself in
all her glory the marvel villain the
hood played by anthony ramos has also
been revealed for the first time the red
coat that gives the character his name
makes him look a bit like the evil
version of little red riding hood he
will presumably not be seen before the
series however we can soon expect the
first appearance of dominique thorne as
iron heart since black panther wakanda
forever will be released in theaters on
november 11 2022 where she will make a
guest appearance
filming of the upcoming the last of a
series has now been completed currently
those responsible have their hands full
with post-production and so it comes in
handy that hbo has announced additional
actors according to ign they are the
hate u give actor lamar johnson the
green mile actor graham green northern
exposure actress elaine miles and
hollywood newcomer kayvon woodard who
already made an appearance in 2018's
seeds of hope woodard and johnson play
the duo henry and sam familiar from the
first video game the two brothers are of
one mind they meet joel and ellie during
the plot and experience part of the
journey together with the two new on the
other hand are green and miles who are
to embody a married couple from wyoming
who make acquaintance with joel and
ellie during the series there is further
news to a first trailer of the hbo
series it won't be too much longer
before the release of the last of us and
recently the first trailer was shown to
the employees of the tv channel the clip
is supposed to be about two and a half
minutes long and give a first impression
of the movie adaptation of their
favorite game which is critically eyed
by many fans according to the clip pedro
pascal in the leading role is hardly
distinguishable from joel from the games
he talks identically and looks like the
role model it looks similar with bella
ramsay as ellie in general hbo has
probably taken over many scenes from the
first game almost one to one as they
appear in the original of course there
are also new scenes that have not been
seen before but all in all game fans
should get their money's worth from the
series we can expect the trailer to be
released soon since it's obviously ready
this year's the last of us day on
september 26th is a possibility this is
based on the day of the outbreak of the
fungal infection and is used every year
to celebrate the franchise in 2021 for
example the very first picture of joe
linely was released on this day it's not
unlikely that we'll get to see the first
trailer on that day this year an exact
launch date for the last of us is not
yet known however as has often been
emphasized in the past the series will
be released by hbo at the beginning of
2023
just about everyone knows the classic
video game pac-man many generations have
fled from the colorful ghosts and have
diligently eaten points now the
franchise is even to be expanded to
include a movie as the hollywood
reporter exclusively reports the
japanese video game publisher bandai
namco is working together with the
studio wayfarer on a live-action movie
adaptation to what extent this
cooperation will turn into a
feature-length blockbuster and as a
live-action format as well it's still
completely unclear originally the video
game was released in 1980 and was
already given two series which were
broadcasted on abc and disney
respectively details especially about
the content are unfortunately not yet
available however the plot is said to be
based on an idea by scriptwriter and
producer chuck williams who already had
a hand in sonic the hedgehog from 2020 a
start date for the pacman movie is not
yet known but we will keep you up to
date
that was the news for this week if you
still have some anticipation left we
warmly recommend our new original on the
best hulk smash scenes there we show the
best scenes of the hulk once again so
that you are well prepared for the soon
to be released she-hulk series we hope
you enjoy
foreign
[Music]